(dramatic music)
(rocket whooshing)
- We're here in southern Ukraine
where the military has
given us very rare access
to HIMARS, which are very
mobile artillery devices.
The Americans have given the Ukrainians 16
of these since June.
(soldier speaking in foreign language)
(mechanism whirring)
- These HIMARS have been critical
to some of the recent
counteroffensives the Ukrainians
have launched against Russian positions.
The systems carry usually six missiles,
which at the moment have
a range of 80 kilometers,
allowing the Ukrainians to strike deeper
into Russian-held territory
than any other system they've had.
The operators we spoke
to this week told us
that these HIMARS now make up 70%
of the firepower deployed
near the frontlines.
These soldiers aren't allowed
by the Ukrainian military
to be identified by their names.
(soldier speaking in foreign language)
(rocket whooshing)
- [Stephen] The HIMARS are
hitting everything at this point.
Ammo depots, headquarters, bridges,
groupings of personnel, tanks, vehicles.
(soldier speaking in foreign language)
(tank roaring)
- [Stephen] These weapon
systems have changed the course
of the war for Ukraine.
They've allowed the military
to start pushing back,
taking back lands as they
have in the past few weeks,
both in the southern front,
as well as in Donbas and up in the north.
(soldier speaking in foreign language)
- [Stephen] Russia's Defense Minister
has told Russian troops
to make Ukraine's long-range
weaponry a priority target
in a sign that Ukraine's
additional firepower
is taking a toll on Moscow's forces.
(tank spinning)
Russia still occupies
large swathes of southern
and eastern Ukraine
and the US has promised
to send 18 more HIMARS
as part of a multi-year plan.
But to fight off Russia's invasion,
Kyiv is also asking for
other advanced weapons,
like tanks and fighter jets
from its Western allies.